OK WE ARE GOING TO START AND I
KNOW WE NEED TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE HERE BECAUSE WE DON'T
QUITE HAVE A QUORUM, BUT, UM
GOOD MORNING, EVERYONE. WE JUST
HAVE THREE BILLS. SO IF YOU'RE
OK, SENATOR JONES WITH
PRESENTING YOUR FIRST THEN WE'LL
COME BACK TO CONSENT. WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM. WOULD THAT BE ALL
RIGHT WITH EVERYONE? MR. JONES?
ARE YOU READY? OK, SENATOR. JOIN
US, PLEASE. AND THEN WE'LL I'LL
STOP YOU IF WE GET A CHANCE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM, BUT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND START. THANK YOU. S¼ B
1225. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M HERE TO PRESENT S¼
B 1225, WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE
BUREAU OF REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS
TO REMOVE NOTICES OF
DISCIPLINARY ACTION FROM THEIR
WEBSITE OF CERTAIN CONDITIONS
ARE MET IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR REMOVAL OF DISCIPLINARY
INFORMATION MUST BE AT LEAST 10
YEARS OLD AND DETERMINED BY THE
BUREAU TO NÓ LONGER BE NECESSARY
TO ENSURE CONSUMER PROTECTION.
LICENSEE DISCIPLINARY
INFORMATION IS A VALUABLE TOOL
IN PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND
PROMOTING TRANSPARENCY. HOWEVER
THERE IS CURRENTLY NÓ WAY FOR
THE BUREAU TO REMOVE THE
INFORMATION WHEN IT'S NÓ LONGER
RELEVANT, SUCH AS WHEN THE
LICENSEE HAS BEEN REHABILITATED.
THE PENALTY HAS BEEN REMOVED AND
MANY YEARS HAVE PASSED. OUTDATED
DISCIPLINARY RECORDS DRAW
ATTENTION AWAY FROM CURRENT ONES
THAT ARE USEFUL IN IDENTIFYING
ACTIVE THREATS TO CONSUMER
PROTECTION. SB 1225 WILL GIVE
THE BUREAU THE AUTHORITY IT
NEEDS TO CLUTTER AND STREAMLINE
ITS DATABASE. ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'LL FIRST
SEE IF ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR YOU. DON'T SEE
ANY AND THEN WE'LL GO. OH YES,
SORRY. BALOS, ANXIOUSLY RAISING
HIS HAND. WOULD YOU LIKE TO HEAR
FROM THE FROM THE PUBLIC FIRST.
NÓ YES, OK, THAT'S FINE. SURE,
ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. THANK
YOU, MIKE ON BEHALF OF THE
APPRAISAL INSTITUTE, THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF REAL
ESTATE APPRAISERS. THIS BILL IS
PREMISED ON THE SAME LANGUAGE IN
THE REAL ESTATE LAW RELATING TO
BROKERS AND SALESPERSONS. WE
WERE ADVISED BY THE BUREAU OF
REAL ESTATE APPRAISERS THAT IN
ORDER TO MAKE THIS CONFORMITY WE
WOULD NEED A BILL, WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE DOING IT. IT SIMPLY GIVES
THE DISCRETION TO THE BUREAU
CHIEF OF BR, BASED ON 10 YEARS
AND REHABILITATION AND NÓ.
CREDIBLE THREAT TO THE PUBLIC OR
IF THE LICENSEE HAS BEEN
DECEASED, AND THE REQUEST COMES
FROM THE FAMILY. SEEMS SIMPLE
AND FAIR, AND, UH, RECOGNIZES
THE PUBLIC INTEREST AND WE WOULD
ASK FOR AN HIGH VOTE. OK
APPRECIATE THAT. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY.
UH, IN SUPPORT OF SB 1025.
SEEING NÓ. ONE WILL SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO 1225. SEEING NÓ ONE I LOOK TO
MY COLLEAGUES. WANTED TO FINISH.
GO AHEAD, SENATOR ARCH. I JUST
WANTED TO SEE THE CORRELATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF REAL
ESTATE AND REAL ESTATE BROKERS
AND LICENSES AND I THINK YOU
ANSWERED THAT. AND IN FACT, MANY
APPRAISERS HAVE REAL ESTATE
BROKERS LICENSES AND SO THEY'RE
SORT OF A CONGRUITY THERE. OK,
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE ROLE NOW
BECAUSE WE HAVE JUST ENOUGH
MEMBERS FOR A QUORUM BEING OUR
GOOD LUCK CHARM. SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU. AND THERE'S A TREE
HERE. ASH TREE HERE WHEN IVA GIL
ALVA GIL HERE, ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HERE, BECKER DODD.
EGGMAN BLAZER, MENGE BAR. MANJAR
NELO NILO HERE. ROTH ROTH HERE,
SMALLWOOD QUAS SMALLWOOD QUAS
HERE, WALK. OK ANY OTHER
DISCUSSIONS ON S¼ B 1225 FROM
THE DÍAS? OK MR JOHN SENATOR
JONES. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
SURE JUST IN CLOSING THE ADD ON
TO MR ARCHER. UH, SENATOR
ARCHULETA COMMENTS. I DID HAVE A
ROUND TABLE WITH A BUNCH OF, UH,
REALTORS DOWN IN SAN DIEGO ON
FRIDAY MENTIONED THIS TO HIM.
AND THEY LIKE THE IDEA, TOO, SO
WE'LL BE WORKING ON LETTERS OF
SUPPORT FROM THEM AS WELL.
GREAT. WE COULD ENTERTAIN
EMOTION IF SOMEBODY WOULD LIKE
TO ALL THAT. SO MOVED. I THINK
THAT WAS SENATOR NILO. ALL
RIGHT. AND WE WILL TAKE THE ROLE
THEN. YEAH. MOTION IS TO PASS TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ASHBY. HØI S¼ P WHEN ALVA DE GIL
ALVAR GIL, I ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
I BECKER DAD, EDMUND GLAZER,
MENJIVAR. MANY OF OUR A NELO
NELO I ROTH ROTH. I SMALLWOOD
QUAS. LOOK. OK WE'RE GONNA LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS. I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT. ALRIGHT. WE CAN. I
THINK WE CAN GO BACK TO CONSENT
NOW? SINCE WE HAVE A QUORUM,
WOULD THAT BE OK? GO AHEAD AND
TAKE UP OUR CONSENT ITEM. WHILE
WE HAVE A QUORUM HERE, WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN, BUT WE WILL.
WE'RE GONNA NEED SENATOR DODD
SOON. OUR THAT MOVED. MOTION TO
WHERE THE CONSENT IS THAT ALL
RIGHT? SO MOVE BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU. ASHBY AYE,
ASHBY. I WHEN ALVA ALVA GILL, I
ARCHULETA CæA I BECKER DODD,
EDMUND LASER MENGE BAR.
MENJIVAR. I NILO NELO I ROTH
ROTH, I SMALL QUIS SMALL
CREVICE. I WILK. OK, WE WILL.
NEED TO WAIT FOR SENATOR DODD TO
GET HERE AND THEN WE'LL WE'LL
HEAR FROM HIM. HE HAS A BILL UP
AND AS HE GETS HERE, WE'LL TAKE
IT OUT.
OK WELL, IF THE CALL FOR THE TWO
ITEMS THAT WE'VE HEARD FIRST
CONSENT UH, CAN I MUST BE 1024
WHEN? WHEN I BECKER DODD, EGM
GLASER WILK. OK, THAT'S A THAT'S
A 88. OK, WE'LL LEAVE. I DID
SEND HER SMALL AQUI VOTE ON THAT
ONE ALREADY. I THINK YOU DID.
JUST NOT ON THE JONES THAT WAS
CONSENT. YEAH YEAH. YOU OK WITH
THAT? OK GREAT. ALL RIGHT, AND
THEN WE'LL TAKE UP SENATOR
JONES, BILL ONE MORE TIME. I
ITEM NUMBER TWO S¼ B 125 MOTIONS
DO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
ABOUT 6 TO 0. WHEN I BECKER,
DODD, EGM GLAZER. SO I WAS VÀ
WALK. YEAH, SO SEVEN. ALRIGHT
THAT'S IT WAS SEVEN. WE'LL PUT
THAT BACK ON CALL FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS, AND WE WILL WAIT FOR
SENATOR DODD.
ALL RIGHT, SENATOR DODD. THANKS
FOR JOINING US. WE'RE GONNA ASK
YOU TO PRESENT ON S¼ B 1384. NOW
IT'S OUR LAST ITEM. SO JUST A
QUICK NOTE TO THE SENATORS WHO
MIGHT BE IN THE BUILDING AFTER
WE HEAR FROM SENATOR DODD. WILL
WE HAVE THE TWO OTHER ITEMS ON
CALL AND WE'LL LEAVE THOSE OPEN
FOR A FEW MINUTES AFTER HE'S
DONE PRESENTING. ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR DODD GO RIGHT AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. S¼ B
1384 WILL ALLOW POWERED
WHEELCHAIR USERS TO HAVE A
VIABLE ALTERNATIVE TO COSTLY AND
TIME CONSUMING REPAIRS BY
ALLOWING CONSUMERS AN
INDEPENDENT REPAIR PROVIDERS
ACCESS TO PARTS, DOCUMENTATION
AND SOFTWARE NECESSARY TO REPAIR
THEIR OWN VEHICLES. THE LIMITED
NUMBERS OF èC R Tð. THAT'S
COMPLEX REHAB TECHNOLOGY SERVICE
PROVIDERS OF THE STATE MEANS
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO USE POWERED
WHEELCHAIRS OFTEN HAVE NÓ OTHER
OPTION BUT TO RELY ON THE
MANUFACTURE FOR REPAIRS. THIS
CAN RESULT IN EXTENSIVE DELAYS,
THUS DECLINING HEALTH AND
MOBILITY USERS. THIS BILL
INCLUDES IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS
FOR CONSUMERS DEFINING THE SCOPE
OF REPAIRS THAT CAN BE SAFELY
CARRIED OUT BY INDEPENDENT
REPAIR PROVIDERS AND PROVIDE A
WRITTEN NOTICE TO CONSUMERS
ABOUT THEIR WARRANTY RIGHTS. WE
MUST PRIORITIZE THE NEEDS OF AND
RIGHTS OF VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
AND S¼ B 1384 IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP TO ACHIEVING THAT GOAL. I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY. DÂN OKEN
FUS, A PUBLIC POLICY MANAGER,
AND RUSSELL RAWLINGS, THE èC R
Tð USER AND STATEWIDE COMMUNITY
MANAGER, BOTH FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION. FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS. UH,
APPRECIATE THIS AND, UH, ALSO
WANTED JUST TO SAY IT'S JUST
BEEN, UH, A VERY POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE WOULD NOT ONLY
WORKING WITH THE ADVOCATES BUT
ALSO WORKING WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS WHO HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY COOPER ALL ALONG THE
WAY. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND YOUR
LEAD WITNESS. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS DÂN OKEN FUSS. I AM THE
PUBLIC POLICY MANAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS.
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY, AND WE
ARE HERE IN, UH, SPONSORSHIP OF
SENATE BILL 1384 GRANTING POWER
WHEELCHAIR USERS, THE ABILITY TO
CONDUCT MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR
SERVICES ON THEIR OWN MOBILITY
DEVICES, IS A STATEWIDE
DISABILITY RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
THAT SERVES AS THE MEMBERSHIP
ASSOCIATION FOR CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS,
WHICH COVER 56 COUNTIES IN THE
STATE, PROVIDING SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND SENATE BILL 13 4 REQUIRE
MANUFACTURERS OF POWER
WHEELCHAIRS TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
NECESSARY TO FACILITATE REPAIRS
AND EQUIPMENT OWNED BY A
CONSUMER, THEREFORE, MAKING IT
EASIER AND FASTER AND MORE
EFFICIENT FOR THE PAIRS TO BE
MADE. FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. MR
ROLLINS. THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU. NICE TO SEE YOU. GOOD
MORNING. THANKS MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING UP THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE. UM S¼ B 1384
REALLY ENSURES ACCESS FOR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES TO TIMELY
REPAIRS. UM, AS SOMEONE WHO'S
USED A èC R Tð POWER WHEELCHAIR
FOR THE ENTIRETY OF THEIR LIFE.
UM I'VE KNOWN WHAT IT'S LIKE TO
WAIT MONTHS, UM FOR REPAIRS AND
REPLACEMENT PARTS FOR CHAIRS. UM
THERE HAVE BEEN FREQUENT TIMES
WHERE I HAVE POPPED INTO A LOCAL
MOM AND POP. BUSINESS TO GET A
SCREW TIGHTENED, BUT THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW FOR ME TO GET MORE
THAN JUST THAT. YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES I'M WAITING ON A PART
FOR, UH FOR MONTHS. THERE HAVE
BEEN TIMES WHEN I'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN LEFT IMMOBILIZED BECAUSE
I'VE HAD TO WAIT UPWARDS OF SIX
MONTHS FOR REPAIR FROM, UM THE,
UH, PROVIDER OF MY WHEELCHAIR.
UH, AND THERE ARE VERY LIMITED
NUMBER OF PROVIDERS THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE PARTS SO S¼ B 1384
WOULD HELP OPEN THIS UP AND GIVE
CONSUMERS MORE OPTIONS. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE. THANK YOU.
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU. OK ARE
THERE OTHERS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S¼ B 1384 HERE IN
THE ROOM? COME ON FORWARD.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE. GOOD
MORNING, KATE LADDISH, CHAIR OF
THE YOLO COUNTY IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND THE YELLOW COUNTY
VOTING ACCESSIBILITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GREAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ANYONE ELSE? ON THIS ONE.
OK HOW ABOUT ANYBODY HERE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO 1384? NOT NÓ SORRY. I'M IN A
NEUTRAL POSITION. UH NOT IN
OPPOSITION, BUT IN A NEUTRAL
POSITION. SO JOHN WINGER ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL COALITION
FOR ASSISTIVE IN REHAB, TECH
TECHNOLOGY, SO WE'RE THE
PROVIDERS AND MANUFACTURERS OF
COMPLEX REHAB TECHNOLOGY JUST
WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
HIS STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE OVER THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF ON THIS BILL, I THINK
WHERE WE'RE AT NOW, WITH THE
STRUCTURE OF THE BILL, WE'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH IT. IT STRIKES
THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN SELF
REPAIR FOR, UH SOME OF THESE
ITEMS AND THEN ALSO MAINTAINING
OF THE CLINICAL OVERSIGHT FOR
SOME OF THE COMPONENTS THAT ARE
A LITTLE BIT MORE COMPLEX. UH,
BUT WE WOULD JUST, YOU KNOW, BE
REMISS IF WE DIDN'T REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT THIS IS A SMALL
PIECE OF THE PROBLEM WITH THE
WHOLE SERVICE AND REPAIR MODEL.
THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE. WE REALLY NEED A
SERVICE CONTRACT KIND OF
FRAMEWORK IN PLACE FOR
PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE SO THAT
WE AVOID A LOT OF THE
CATASTROPHIC FAILURES THAT
RENDER SOME OF THESE VULNERABLE
PATIENTS IN BEDS FOR WEEKS AT A
TIME. UH, WE ALSO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT REIMBURSEMENT
CHALLENGES. WE DON'T GET FOR
TRAVEL. EVEN THOUGH WE PAY, WE
SPEND 86% OF OUR TIME IN THE
FIELD. UH, WE DON'T GET PAID FOR
MOST OF OUR LABOR. AND SO IT'S
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED,
COMPLICATED AND DIFFICULT
SERVICE PROCESS FOR US, AND SO
WE THANK THE AUTHOR AGAIN. UH, A
LOT OF THE PROGRESS WE MADE LAST
YEAR ON PRIOR AUTHORIZATION IS
GETTING WORKED THROUGH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT. THAT'S GONNA BE
HELPFUL. THIS WILL BE HELPFUL,
BUT THERE'S A LOT MORE WE NEED
TO DO. AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THAT ENGAGEMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER FOLKS HERE IN THE
ROOM? WANT TO TESTIFY ON THIS?
ANY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
COMMENTS? GO AHEAD, SENATOR
ARCHULETA. AND THEN AFTER THAT,
SENATOR, WHAT A GREAT BILL AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE,
BUT I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT OVER
THE YEARS FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
HAVE MECHANICS OR FRIENDS WHO
ARE VERY, UH, MECHANICALLY
ORIENTED COULD NOT HAVE WORKED
ON SOME OF THESE CHAIRS AND NOT
RECEIVE THE PARTS. UH IS IT HAS
BEEN LIKE THAT, AND HAVE YOU NOT
BROUGHT EVERYBODY TOGETHER, IT
WOULD CONTINUE. YES BUT BUT I
DON'T WANT THIS TO SOUND LIKE AN
INDICTMENT. NECESSARILY IN ALL
THE MANUFACTURERS, I YOU KNOW A
LOT OF TIME. IT'S THE APPROVALS
BY ME, TOO, THAT TAKE SO DARN
LONG IN THE SYSTEM AND
EVERYTHING. SO I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT, UH UH, YOU KNOW,
EVERYBODY COULD HAVE DONE A
BETTER JOB. CERTAINLY BUT I
THINK WITH COVID. WE FOUND OUT
JUST HOW ACUTE IT WAS, UH AND
WHY SOMETHING NEEDED TO BE DONE
NOW, SO I APPRECIATE THAT ARE
THANK GOD YOU YOU BROUGHT IT
FORWARD AND I'LL MOVE THE BILL
WHEN IT'S TIME. THANK YOU, MA'AM
. CHAIR, SENATOR. YOU KNOW, I
JUST LAST YEAR I JOINED MISTER
JOHN OVER HERE IN A LOCATION IN
MICE IN MY DISTRICT WHERE I
LEARNED, YOU KNOW HOW LONG
INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO WAIT TO GET
SOMETHING FIXED. I AM SO GLAD
WE'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. I KNOW YOU JUST
WHISPERED INTO INTO OUR EAR HERE
THAT NEXT YEAR WE NEED TO REALLY
HELP WITH THE REIMBURSEMENT AND
SHORTEN THAT TIME PERIOD. I
THINK THIS IS THE, UM STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. I HOPE AND
WE GET IT BACK TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK AGAIN. AND THIS TIME HE
SIGNS IT AND I DO AGREE WITH, UH
JOHN OVER HERE THAT WE NEED TO
DO BETTER AND MOVE FORWARD AND
CLOSING THE GAP HERE BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF BARRIERS TO
GETTING, UM A LOT OF THESE, UH,
MISSIONARY FIX AND INTO THE INTO
THE HANDS OF INDIVIDUALS THAT
NEED IT. TO, UM TO MOVE
THROUGHOUT THEIR DAY. SO THANK
YOU SO MUCH. I WISH THAT I WOULD
BE HERE NEXT YEAR TO BE ABLE TO
RUN THAT BILL, BUT THAT'S
IMPOSSIBLE. WELL YOU'RE WELCOME
TO COME BACK AND TESTIFY AND
JOIN US. OK ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
COLLEAGUES WISHING TO SPEAK FIND
YOU IN HAWAII. ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR DODD. YOU WANNA CLOSE? I
JUST REALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS AND THE QUESTIONS AND,
UH AND TO THE ADVOCATES THAT
HAVE JUST DONE AN AMAZING JOB
FROM DAY ONE. I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY COMING TOGETHER ON
THIS RESPECTFULLY. LAST YEAR I
VOTE OK, AND WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR ARCH, SO WE WILL
TAKE ROLE HERE. QUESTION IS DO
PASS THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. ASHBY, I ASHBY, I
WIN. HØI WHEN I ALVA DE GIL ALVA
GIL, I ARCHULETA ARCHULETA. I
BECKER BECKER. I DODD I EGM
EDMUND I. GLAZER. MENJIVAR
MENJIVAR A MILO MILO I, ROTH
ROTH. I S¼ SMALLWOOD CREVIS
SMALLWOOD CREVICE I WILK WHILK I
GOT 12. OK 12 ON THAT ONE. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE TO YOUR YOUR
WITNESS THERE, MR DODD. ALL
RIGHT. WE HAVE THE OTHER TWO
ITEMS. I THINK WE'LL GO BACK AND
OPEN THE CALL ON THOSE. PROBABLY
JUST A NOTE HERE TO ANY SENATORS
IN THE BUILDING WHO'D LIKE TO
COME DOWN? WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
ALL THREE HERE AND TAKE THEM
THROUGH ONE TIME, AND THEN WE'LL
WAIT A COUPLE OF MINUTES AND DO
IT AGAIN. SO THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE AND THE
ONES WHO ARE ON THEIR WAY DOWN.
GO AHEAD. ITEM NUMBER ONE YOUR
MIC IS WE'LL START WITH 1024.
YOUR ITEM NUMBER ONE S¼ B 1024
CURRENT VOTES 8 TO 0 BECKER
BECKER I, DODD DODD. I EG EG I
GLAZER WHILK WHILK, AYE. 12 TO
0. OK 12 0. WE'RE GONNA THAT
ONE'S DONE THEN WE'RE GOING TO
SEND THAT TO WE NEED ONE MORE
VOTE NÓ. HE'S NOT COMING. HE'S
NOT COMING, CORRECT. OK, THEN,
LET'S CLOSE IT OUT. CLOSE IT OUT
THAT ONE'S CLOSED OUT. HØI YOU.
ITEM NUMBER TWO S¼ B 1225
CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO 0 BECKER.
ID, DO I EGM EDMUND I LASER
FORWARD PLAYS WELCOME. WELCOME,
AYE. IT'S 11 AND NUTS OUT.
THAT'S 11. SO SENATOR JONES THAT
ONE'S OUT YOU CAN CALL THIS FOR
ONE MORE TIME. ALL RIGHT. ONE
LAST CALL ON EITHER. DODD'S BILL
ITEM NUMBER THREE S¼ B 1384.
CURRENT VOTES. 12 TO 0 GLAZER.
OK ALL RIGHT, SO THAT ONE'S ALSO
12 RIGHT? 12 NÓ THAT ONE'S OUT
AND ON TO JUDS, THANKS TO ALL
THE MEMBERS FOR SHOWING UP THAT
IS IT FOR THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY.